[Music]
was here weekend oh my god what the [ __ ]
it was below average the edge of
seventeen is a brilliant coming-of-age
comedy NIC is so hot
he works at petland now I should go in
there and be like excuse me where the
betta fish and do you want to have sex
right now
hell yeah not you it joins the ranks of
classics like clueless Mean Girls and
Fast Times at Ridgemont High are you so
awkward it's a true original why don't
you try what I do when I'm feeling down
um I say to myself everyone is as
miserable as I am there's just better
pretending pick a god any God and thank
them for this movie Nick I like you and
I just want to be with you I want you to
put your mouth like tits and I want to
feel you inside me we can do it in the
petland stockroom maybe I can't send
this huh no no no no oh my god no oh the
edge of 17 this isn't so bad I just want
to be with you want you to put your
mouth on my tits I want to feel you in
silence God we can do it in the petland
stockroom
oh my god say something please help me
you need to watch out for run-on
sentences way across the country to rob
a goddamn charity associate who's got
this thing all lined up what associate
[ __ ] stake mom he's